I've got to meet hang out with Ali Abdul
Aziz he's a hands of Gracie black belt
fourth degree Judo black belt and friend
and manager of khabib nurmagametov who's
coming down uh to Austin soon we'll do a
podcast hopefully you get on the mat and
have have a bit of brainstorm
um also he's a manager and friend of
many other amazing Fighters
um
I really love the guy uh the Loyalty The
the fact that he he looks for loyalty
and has that inner close Inner Circle
and uh integrity and character and
people I really like them I connect them
really quickly but any any fun stories
about Ollie did you train together yeah
so he trained for many years in the uh
in the basement of my classes
um uh he's
is his story is one of the most unlikely
stories like if someone wrote a movie
plot about his life they'd be like this
it's absurd it would be thrown out the
door in a second and yet it all happened
um uh
you're absolutely correct he his
from the unlikeliest possible starts
created a situation where he's I think
it's incontestable now to say he's the
most successful manager in mixed martial
arts history he has more Champions under
his care than than anyone else I've I'm
aware of and respected and influential
so on on all Dimensions yes now many
people aren't aware the fact that he was
actually a very good judo player he had
um judoka first yes yeah he had very
good uh nogi Judah
um he had an excellent haraigoshi uh
very good Tania Toshi
um and he through many people who were
highly credentialed wrestlers in back in
the basement back in the Glory Days of
MMA training
um he was a good example of a guy who
had very very good Judo hips and often
use it to to counter wrestling and uh
was a fine demonstrator of the idea that
when Judo was adapted to nogi gripping
it can provide a very effective foil to
many of the standard forms of wrestling
attack and he would often use uchamada
to counter leg tackles and do some very
very spectacular fashion